good morning Hank it's Tuesday Hank some
days some days I just want to be a
professional critic of gifs featuring
animals interrupting sporting events and
field cat is of course a classic of the
genre in which a cat finds itself on the
pitch for a Liverpool game is the cat
trying to reflect something about
Liverpool's own confused inconsistent
defending know I think Anfield cats
indecision is best read as a metaphor
for human life itself isolated afraid
but still resilient Squirrel interrupts
US Open reminds us that it's not only
human animals who can display their
talents on a tennis court the height of
that jump the squirrels Bowl etic run
followed by a pause at the center of the
net to ensure that everyone is watching
and then yes observe that jaunty run
ultimately Hank sports is not only about
winning and losing it's also about
displaying what physical bodies can do
including and perhaps especially
squirrel bodies dog pooping at baseball
game wouldn't usually be my kind of gift
I prefer the higher brow animals
interrupting sporting events animations
but despite the grainy lo-fi camerawork
here there's something very compelling
the dog is literally crapping on the
game as if to say I reject your
obsessive fascination with sports the
dog seems to be asking which of us is
really sentient you mindlessly watching
men attempt to hit a ball with a wooden
stick or me elegantly articulating my
feelings via defecation
now of course dog on the pitch is so
common that it's a world unto itself but
what moves me about dog on the pitch in
all its iterations is the reminder by
the dogs that sports are ultimately
about play for me the comic pinnacle
here is goalkeeper dog catcher failed
but the greatest of these gifts
unquestionably
is drug dog wants to play this Swift and
relentless attack of the ball asks many
important questions are there drugs in
the ball what kind of drugs could you
put in a soccer ball would it affect the
performance of the ball and most
importantly why wasn't Air Bud three
world pup a better movie like all great
gifs Mexican drug dog wants to play
refuses to answer these questions
directly or in a fully satisfying way
instead this work of art leaves us
unsettled but enlarged Fox absconds with
golf ball is another brilliant rejection
of sport itself the Fox seems to be
saying you believe you can come onto
this course and escape the ambiguity and
randomness that haunts every moment of
life on earth but no matter how well
you water the greens and mow the
fairways I will be here to remind you
that you will never escape it and that
brings us to what is in my opinion the
greatest animal interrupting a sporting
event gif of all time hanck most sports
stories lack a complex moral narrative
like you want Rudy to play because he's
little and he's full of hustle you want
that guy from The Blind Side to become
that guy from the Baltimore Ravens
because he had a hard life and Sandra
Bullock loves him you want Teen Wolf to
make the Big Shot because he has long
suffered under the twin burdens of
teenager hood and werewolf dome but Hank
while we craved that moral simplicity
the truly great animals interrupting
sporting event gifs refused to give it
to us and to my mind the greatest among
them is of course pine marten invades
swiss soccer match first there's the
shocking surprise that switzerland has a
professional football league not to
mention the quality of the footage in
the camerawork then there's the full
throated commitment of both the pine
marten who wishes to stay on the pitch
and it's human defender who wishes to
remove it from the pitch now making most
stories the heroes are simply good and
the villains are simply evil but for
whom are we to root in this gift when
the pine marten bites the human we
naturally feel put off it isn't sporting
to bite a fellow competitor on the other
hand the defender has clearly fouled the
pine marten tackling it from behind as
it races toward the goal that's a red
card who is the victim who is the
perpetrator who is good who is bad like
all great interrogations of the universe
pine marten invade swiss soccer pitch
offers no easy answer instead it asks us
to consider the possibility that the
pine marten the defender and indeed each
of us contain multitudes Hank I'll see
you on Friday